six one seven eight three zero 4750
here's something risky we're gonna take
our next call from country code 49
I have no [ __ ] no clue what country code
49 is but who's where is country code 49
and who is this is beacon calling from
Germany can you understand me well we
can understand you find Daniel go ahead
perfect okay so my question isn't about
American politics I hope that's okay
well let's see what the question is and
then we'll evaluate and the question is
maybe you've noticed that Republican guy
Paula Newlin posting this list on
Twitter of Jews who attack him on this
statement they have not seen that list
of Jews now okay so something that I
noticed recently is in the wake of the
odd right that this rhetoric of you know
Jews controlling the media and all that
stuff it's becoming even more prominent
than getting into the mainstream and
together with that is also things like
Holocaust denial or that just ridiculous
stuff um what is your opinion on
engaging this sort of stuff is it worth
even trying to debunk it or would you
just try to ignore it all no I I think
it's it's tough to go head-to-head and
try and debunk that stuff so I think a
better general practice is not to get
involved I do think it's important you
know big picture if if stereotypes are
sort of perpetrated never with any
opposition it can be problematic because
it can appear to legitimize those hey
listen people are saying this over and
over again nobody's refuting it so maybe
there is something to it
so I think big picture it's important to
make clear that those types of
stereotypes and prejudices are
considered invalid and discriminatory
but at sort of the individual level it's
sort of a personal choice whether you
want to get into like a
point-counterpoint debate about Jews
controlling media for example and if
you're going to engage I think it's like
the Jews controlling media is a good
example for us to talk about one
approach would be to try to give counter
examples of how Jews don't control media
or something like that but that's never
going to can
Vincente conspiracy theorist I think a
better approaches to say listen whether
or not for historical reasons Jew and
Jewish individuals might be
over-represented in certain industries
relative to their population the idea of
a conspiracy to control and working in
concert is absolutely not backed by
evidence and sort of picking it apart
that way rather than trying to provide
examples of a Christian who's in media
you know I think that that the latter is
not nearly as effective I see ok well
then thanks for answering my question
all right appreciate it Daniel great to
hear from Germany very hiding I gotta
ask how do you square that viewpoint
with your choice to interview Richard
Spencer other racist and anti-semite
this is a program I mean they're the
leaders of these causes leaders of the
causes is different but also this is a
program where this it's sort of what
we're doing we're exploring and exposing
these ideas and I challenge my sense was
that the caller was asking more on sort
of like a in a day-to-day mundane way or
something like Joe down the street
sure Joe Nazi down the street or
whatever you want to call them